revelation. That's why he he grabbed him
three times hard and he said afraid
about to die. Then he let me go and he
said read or recite said what should I
recite or said I cannot read different
ways of mention it as said so now then
he said what should I read say read in
the name of your lord even the verse
that Allah revealed the first time knew
this not human speech even his own
people knew this not human speech
these verses. That's why the Quran style
and structure
in the history no humans speaks the way
the Quran speaks.
By the way, we know what is the meaning.
What is alle mean? Why Allah puts it
there? As for people say no one knows
the meaning of it. His opinion is
incorrect because Allah taught us he
sent down the Quran for us to reflect
upon it.
challenge the people to bring something
like it because the Arab pagans they
were saying we cannot understand what
prophet Muhammad is saying even though
they were speaking Arabic language so
they start acting like a foolish you see
and this is the outcome some people
because when they cannot refute the
truth either they becoming aggressive or
they start becoming foolish okay so
Allah put this letters to show them this
Quran consists of the letters that you
utilize to you speak in your own
language
So alhamdulillah that so squeeze in
three times and the Arab the Arab
culture as well is they address you
three times.
>> Y
>> that's the Arab culture by the way.
>> So like prophet Muhammad he used to say
to Sah Muad.
So Mu said oh messenger Allah I'm here
for you at your service. Then he said oh
muad three times. That is the culture of
the Arabs back then.
>> Yeah. Then I have another question. So
um so there was this there was this guy
that I met in uh in a shop called HC
speakers.
>> You what? There was there was this there
was this guy I met
>> in a shop called HC Scooters.
>> HC. What the heck is that?
>> Polyground trade scooters.
>> Oh okay.
>> And um basically he's he's super
Christian but he doesn't follow
Christian correctly. So, see that's the
problem he becomes super because you go
beyond super goes it goes beyond.
>> I know he just every day he just he
always like promote this so much cuz he
said he told me that apparently he met
Jesus.
>> He met where he went?
>> Uh no in a in a Russian speaking church
in Bristol. In Bristol I don't know
Christians they met Jesus but they have
different story and Jesus look different
ways.
>> Yeah I know one met him with dreadlocks
one met him with a skin fade.
Caribbeans, I'm sorry, Jamaicans, they
have Jesus, which is J look.
>> Yeah,
>> that one they have with the blonde blue
eyes and a blonde hair. That middle
east, they have the way like middle
eastern look. Go ahead. So basically he
said that. So he's really confused. It's
like apparently you know how like in
Christianity kind of anywhere anytime.
>> Yeah. We call supplication. Yes. And
he's so he thinks that in Islam you have
to be fixated in one place. You have to
like you have to no you have to we pray
>> but not anywhere we don't pray in dirty
places.
>> Imagine someone that you highly respect
and say I want I want to have a word
with you. You take him to the toilet.
So let's have
some you understand.
>> So that's why look even the teacher
before you speak to the creator you
purify yourself. There's two way two
ways of purification. Purity of inside
and outside.
>> Inside you purify yourself from
jealousy, envy. And before all of this,
purify yourself from shik and disbelief
which is the worst dirty
impurity. Spiritual impurity. Yes.
Spiritual impurity to have within you.
Yeah. Then you purify yourself
physically and you speak to Allah.
However, for supplication, you don't
have to have voodoo anywhere. You can
anyone say anywhere. Anywhere. you can
like now raise your hand for Allah, you
know. Alhamdulillah.
>> Then I'm I'm guessing uh you know that
that guy he misunderstands a lot. Yeah.
Just kid
Christians say that. Yeah. So you
Muslims you cannot pray to God whenever
you like no you can pray to Allah like I
raise my hands to Allah
and a Muslim when he is working he's
praying to Allah. If he's working to
provide for his family that's a worship
Allah will reward him for that. In Islam
worship doesn't mean you have to be
inside the mosque 24 hours. That is one
of the aspect of worship not to be 24
hours in the mosque except if you have
nowhere to stay. Okay. However, that
like now removing something harmful that
is an act of worship if you do it for
the sake of Allah. Taking care of your
neighbors that is an act of worship.
Taking care of your parents for all of
the you know humans that is an act of
worship. you know looking after the poor
people, the orphans, what do they call
it? Uh uh
>> the homeless.
>> Homeless that is an act of worship. See
worship in Islam is a comprehensive word
comprise many things you know and and
and and stopping the oppressor from
oppression that is act of worship. If we
doing it if you're doing for the sake of
Allah